Well, day two of testimony
wrapped up on Friday
and the double murder
trial of Alex Murdaugh,
the disbarred and disgraced South
Carolina attorney
charged with killing his wife and son.
Excuse me, Murdaugh has not has pleaded
not guilty.
Here's CNN's correspondent Randi
Kaye with more on what we heard
from Murdaugh
on the night of the killings.
We had a wonderful marriage,
wonderful relationship
in yours and Paul's relationship,
as good as it could be.
This is Alex Murdaugh
being interviewed
in the investigators
car hours
after his wife and son were murdered.
I mean, I pulled up and I could see him
I could see it was
and I could see
his brain
And I ran over to Maggie, and
actually,
I think I tried to turn Paul over first,
try to take their pulse on both of them.
Mm hmm.
And, you know,
I called 911.
Pretty much right away.
That conversation took place
at nearly 1 a.m.
on June 8th. 20, 21.
For the first time,
we hear him explain how
he says
he tried to reach his wife and son
with no luck.
I got up.
I called Maggie.
Didn't get an answer.
And
I think I texted her
and she's very good
about answering the phone.
So that was odd. Or calling me back.
So that was odd.
But it wasn't that big a deal.
I texted her.
at 9:08 going to check on him.
Be right back.
And then I texted her at 9:47.
That must be
when I started to come back
and make a called her.
Before that,
let me make sure
you're pretty sure.
And I called her
at 9:45
and then I tried.
Paul.
Alex Murdaugh told investigators
that he tried to check the pulse
on both his wife Maggie and son Paul.
Yet Alex
didn't appear to have any blood on him.
This investigator told the court.
Did you see anything that appeared
to be blood on his feet? I did not.
Did you see what appeared to be blood
on Alex's mobile phones? I did not.
And when the defense lawyer asked her
why she thought his clothes
were freshly washed,
he sweating and they are dry.
So I would say, yes, sir.
Still, on
cross-examination,
the defense tried to poke holes
in the idea
that Alex Murdaugh
may have washed his clothes
after allegedly killing his wife and son.
Well, let me ask you, in your mind's eye,
that night
on June 7th, did
he look like someone had just blown
his son's head off?
Spatter going everywhere
Again, I can't say that for sure.
Also in court, a crime scene investigator
at one point pulled out Paul Murdoch's
bloody sneakers
that he was wearing the night
he was killed.
That was certainly a dramatic moment.
And that same witness
who was testifying for the state
said that investigators
didn't search Alex Murdaugh's home
until September 13th.
2021.
That would have been
more than three months
after the double murder.
No doubt the defense,
when it does cross-examination on Monday,
will use that to continue its theme
of an alleged sloppy investigation Amara.
Wow. So many fascinating details there.
Randi Kaye.
Thank you for your reporting.
Joey Jackson
is a criminal defense attorney and CNN
legal analyst.
Joey, I know you've been quite busy,
so thank you so much for
joining us this morning.
First off, Joey,
I mean, it seems like
there is a lot of smoke there
What did you make?
First of all,
what we heard from that officer
who was first
to respond at the murder scene
and how he said that Alex Murdaugh
didn't cry
when he saw him
and that he immediately offered up
a possible motive
Yeah.
Hammer, good morning to you.
You know,
this is a tough case in general,
I think, for the prosecution.
And as much as we are in a really DNA
era right
we're in an era where people need to see
juries need to see
no one observe in the event
someone's guilty in this particular case.
Just broadly
speaking, before
the specifics of your question,
You look
and you say, well,
is there any surveillance
which would indicate that he did it?
Well, no.
Are there any eyewitnesses
that would indicate that he did it?
Well, no.
Is there anything else
that you could suggest where
other than circumstantial evidence,
to say that he actually is
the one who is responsible answered no.
And so then you go to the specifics
and you ask me the question
with respect to was we look at that.
He's charged with the murder of his son
and his wife. Right.
The victim was found shot to death
on the family property June of 20, 21
and of course, he's pleaded not guilty.
But people have different ways
of which they respond, Amara,
in the event, for example, of a death.
Right.
You cross-examine
someone, you indicate
that he wasn't crying,
but you did say that he seemed upset.
Is there a standard way
in which someone should react
in a situation like this?
Would you believe
the two people might respond the same
or may they respond differently?
So it's always tough to make judgments
with respect to the demeanor,
the comportment
and the attitude of someone
in a horrific situation.
To the extent that everyone is different.
So that in and of itself,
my answer is not outcome determinative
as to his guilt.
What about this question about why
he didn't have any blood on his clothes
or his hands, even though
Alex Murdoch said
that he checked the pulse
of his wife and son?
How do you explain that?
Yes.
So, you know,
that could
be problematic
inasmuch as you could say
one of two things, right?
You could say that he didn't have it
inasmuch as he wiped it off. Right.
That's what
the prosecution is alluding to,
the fact that he tried
to clean himself up.
But then on the other hand. Right.
You're the police.
You've conducted an investigation.
Did you attempt to make any efforts
to determine whether there was blood
you didn't see?
Did you do any other investigation
to see whether or not there was blood
at any other parts of his body?
Did you get a warrant
to make an assessment as to his home
or anything else?
Did you look at other areas for which
you might suggest
that he could have wiped the blood off?
Did you find a clot?
Did you do anything else
And so I think that there's
always two narratives.
Just like your other question,
was he setting up an alibi?
Well,
maybe instead of setting up an alibi,
he was simply trying to determine
what was going on
and giving you information
so that you officers
could get to the bottom of it.
Maybe instead of wiping off blood. Right.
He actually just based upon
where the spatter was,
that was not the blood
and that particular location.
Right.
Of the wrist
or where he was trying to do it.
So there's innocent explanations.
And then there are nefarious
explanations trials
and are about the prosecution
pointing to the nefarious
and defense pointing to the innocent
and the jury making a determination
as to
what do those two narratives make sense?
Okay.
So sounds like
this is going to be an uphill battle
in terms of proving with evidence
for prosecutors.
What do you expect the defense
to do or what their strategy will be?
Yeah, I
think they'll continue to
pound on what they have.
I mean, the fact is, is that
what type of investigation did you do?
Where is the specific proof
in the evidence?
Where is the connection to him?
Well, Art, that is Alex Murdaugh.
What is the motivation
as to why he would do this?
How are you suggesting without evidence
with respect to eyewitnesses that he did
without surveillance, that he did
without blood on his all
about his body part
Now, look, here's here's the point.
When you heard the cross-examination
that we did,
if his defense attorney, Amara,
he was pointing out that in the event
that there splatter and some
I mean, it's pretty graphic
that I won't get into.
But if people you're shooting him
in the head area,
you would expect blood to splatter.
So was it on his shirt?
Was that on his face?
What Islamist pants?
Did you make any analysis
did you make any assessment?
So what do we have
circumstantial evidence
because you think he's guilty.
That's not enough.
Ladies and gentlemen.
And I think that's where the defense
will go and continue
to hammer away in the case.